[Musique]
madame bakker à 70 ans tous les jours ma
tous les jours je suis en train de faire
un petit peu de gymnastique il marque
deux enfants de m beaucoup parce que
j'ai fait que courir après eux
[Musique]
j'ai maintenant 54 kg et quand j'étais
jeune j'ai vu cinquantaine de kilos de
relance
c'est bien
[Musique]
les gens savaient pas si j'étais une
gassmann fillon me suivez parce que
j'avais les cheveux coupés
c'était en 1926 elle vient de
philadelphie avec la revue [ __ ]
débarque à cherbourg un mois plus tard
au théâtre des champs-elysées c'est le
scandale la france pourtant radical et
bon enfant de gaston doumergue s'indigne
elle tient du kangourou boxeur et du
coureur cycliste lisez les critiques
elle déshonore le music hall elle
apporte en fait aux français charleston
et le black bottom le match des filles
aînées ce sont les années folles est
légal les plus grandes lamia fréhel
la miss
chevallier souvenez vous
on va rire et chanter pendant quinze ans
sur les scènes parisiennes optimiste
envers et contre tout ça ne va pas durer
[Musique]
aux premiers bruits de bottes joséphine
part pour le
lieutenant aviateurs bakker aux sans
voix plus tard la légion d'honneur
[Musique]
je suis
discret
[Musique]
angleterre égide
partout dans le désert afrique du nord
revenons ici que cetera et cetera
qu'est ce qu'on vaut mieux ce que je
devais faire et on se dit très fier de
pouvoir le faire d'ailleurs
deviner
le
nom j'ai chanté le temps à autre mais
surtout je faisais de la résistance
parce que j'avais qu'une seule chose en
tête c'est à dire de aider
la france de remontrer comme l'était
avant qu'il avait très peur du commun
qui ne commenceront la guerre mais c'est
un petit moment là leur
qui
dis moi joséphine va me revoir
dis moi josé pinto est lésé témoin dans
toi je te dis
quelle joie pour moi que
believe
[Musique]
mes sous
new
delhi la grande joséphine l'époque team
star a livré dans des villes à son dieu
c'est le tas comme me demander tous et
ces questions juste comment voulez vous
que je vous avoue de reprendre de la
stalle
je ne suis rien de tout ça
et je n'étais jamais rien j'étais
adoptée par paris et ensuite par le
monde on m'a mis sur crystal et j'ai
accepté avec joie bien sûr mais accumule
de dette pas réfléchi passage je rêvais
la vie d'artiste de 9 heures et je
n'aime toujours
la chance ou celui nous en tête sur la
scène s'exprimer avec tant de bonheur
est donc un petit strass et plumes étude
de belles choses que tout faire femmes m
ils ont posé par terre et il ya quatre
gars qui sont venus deux devant et
derrière que gentiment la baquère
et qu'ils ont dépensé par terre
après les fastes la chute joséphine et
son mari jo bouillon ont acheté le
château des milandes pour les enfants de
tous les pays qu'ils sont adoptés mais
la reine du show on n'entend rien au
business en 68 le rêve s'effondre malgré
l'opinion publique les milandes sont
vendus au dixième de leur valeur et
joséphine remonte sur scène pour éponger
les dettes
[Musique]
ça
tu fais ça tu lèves
merano voit
[Musique]
jamais
et peut-être c'est une des raisons je
t'aime entaché mes enfants parce que
j'étais une maman innée mais pas en
effet ces enfants sont ils maintenant
avec moi commenté cas classés la
princesse nous avons une maison et
autant que nous voulons restons le
stella nouristan qu'est-ce qu'ils font
peur aux enfants des étudiants
celle qu'il aime pas beaucoup savent
carrousel mais en fait faut lever du
jour grecque est bien là tout petit avec
dix ans marien 18 ans et demi comme il
dit et mon fils est né avec trois ans
il vaudrait nous deux enfants s'en
contente les autres vous par exemple
parce que je vous avez adopté mais vous
savez qu'à la mi-mars
m
[Musique]
et d'aucuns de
mollo
[Musique]
par vous
là aussi
seulement
kopitar
poteau
moi je suis malheureuse quand on me dit
mais enfin joséphine vous savez vous
côté bien encore et j'ai tous déjà de
trop c'est comme si on sépare regarder
dans le dollar dans le mémoire et selon
le compte soit même des années qui
passent
pour l'heure devant la greffe tout le
temps tous les matins quand je fais
maquillage et tout ça suis bien obligé
le garder et je me rende compte de tout
sûr c'est tellement naturel et normal je
suis habitué à ça et oui tous les jours
chaque jour où on a une ride de plus qu
en âge que moi ou n'importe quoi de plus
difficultés de gouges et peut-être aussi
passé 6 ou pour qu'avant mais tout ça
c'est tout naturel
j'ai la chance de pouvoir
être avec nous ce soir
[Musique]
il
arrive
[Musique]